bonjour raymond moretti sera le
principal invité de cette émission de
tf1 actualité moretti avec une immense
fresque réalisée au coeur de paris
quartier des halles nous sommes en ce
moment
moretti tout le monde le connaît avec
une autre oeuvre gigantesque gigantesque
le monstre installé lui sous le quartier
de la défense à paris nous en parlons
tout à l'heure mais aujourd'hui donc
nous nous trouvons en direct des halles
dans ce fameux trou aujourd'hui
reboucher et quinze jours avant
l'inauguration de ce qui sera le centre
du nouveau quartier le forum des halles
centre commercial mais aussi culturel
nous parlerons de ce forum tout à
l'heure avec d'autres invitent la
fresque de moretti c'est la première
fois que vous la voyez derrière nous
elle se trouve dans une rue du nouveau
forum des halles à 15 mètres sous terre
et on est surtout frappé par sa
dimension au raymond moretti alors
quelle est sa taille et elle a une
cinquantaine de mètres de long sur 4 2
au donc 200 m² environ
et combien de temps de travail propre à
la vanille oui on est quand même frappé
moretti par le fait que vous attaquez
surtout à des oeuvres absolument
gigantesque déjà le monstre installé
maintenant à la défense a une taille
considérable cette phrase qui fait quand
même 250 m² en gros donc tout le monde
et qui intègre tous mais vous faites des
timbres poste nous puis des choses très
petit je dessine en avons beaucoup
qu'elle est quel est le grand thème de
cette fresque une trentaine de cette
fret c'est l'homme tout simplement les
lobes du côté de l'homme côté physique
et le côté culturel vous dire aussi vous
êtes un pâtre de l'actualité vous faites
des portraits pour des journaux je fais
des couvertures de journaux
un peu tout et des prêts pochettes de
disques enfin c'est je trouve que c'est
le même job mais raymond moretti tout à
l'heure nous détaillerons cette phrase
que nous reviendrons aussi sur le forum
des halles avec nos invités
et puis cette actualité dont nous
parlions raymond moretti a accepté de
l'illustré spécialement pour ce journal
pour tf actualité alors l'actualité avec
éric gilbert et les illustrations
vraiment moritz les trains d'abord sur
les voies le signal rouge sera mis dans
la soirée la grève démarre
officiellement à minuit mais par
précaution beaucoup de trains de nuit
seront supprimés à l'origine de ce
mouvement qui s'annonce dur les
conditions de travail des agents de
conduite commentaires de jacques le noir
bien que la grève ne commence ce soir
qu'à minuit on peut s'attendre à des
perturbations dès 20h au départ des
gares de lyon et d'austerlitz cette
grève déroulant qui doit durer 48 heures
a toutes les chances d'être très
largement suivi car elle est organisée
par les trois principaux syndicats cgt
cfdt et autonome qui représentent à eux
seuls la quasi totalité des agents de
conduite aussi sur les grandes lignes la
sncf ne prévoit tel qu'un train sur cinq
au total en province une soixantaine de
trains seulement circuleront demain et
jeudi pour la banlieue parisienne le
trafic ne sera assuré qu'à 25% et sur
certaines lignes comme paris orly il
sera totalement supprimée alors un
conseil pour tous renseignements appeler
ce numéro de téléphone le 261 55 ans si
les cheminots ont décidé de paralyser le
réseau ferroviaire en plein mois d'août
c'est d'abord pour protester contre la
suppression d'un deuxième agent de
conduite sur chaque train une mesure qui
affirme-t-il menace plusieurs milliers
d'emplois et puis ils réclament aussi
une amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail notamment une réduction de la
durée du travail
il prévoit d'ailleurs une nouvelle
action pour la mi-septembre à laquelle
cette fois participeront non seulement
les roulants mais l'ensemble des
chenilles
les réactions après la conférence de
presse de françois mitterrand en
qualifiant la politique actuelle du
gouvernement je cite deux plus grands et
de plus grave échec de la politique
française depuis l'après guerre
françois mitterrand hier à lancer une
attaque très durs contre le pouvoir et
contre monsieur giscard d'estaing en
précisant le premier responsable c'est
le président de la république mais en
réclamant d'autre part la relance de
l'union et une gauche de salut public
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste a aussi voulu mettre les
communistes au pied du mur jacques
hébert bien depuis deux ans depuis
l'échec des législatives les partis de
l'opposition mme annie cet art tout à
fait originale qui consiste à mettre
l'autre chacun son tour au pied du mur
à défaut de pouvoir le gravir ensemble
vous demandez l'union à la base et bien
chiche a dit en substance hier françois
mitterrand à georges marchais réponse ce
matin de l'humanité en ces quelques
lignes très sèche de commentaire une
action unitaire dans l'entreprise ou le
quartier la ville ou la région vaut
mieux que des déclarations d'intention
celle exprimée hier par françois
mitterrand sont peu susceptibles de
démentir cette réalité tenace en fait
les propos de françois mitterrand
semblait plus s'adresser aux militants
socialistes qu'au parti communiste des
militants socialistes encore troublé par
les divisions du congrès de metz et les
résultats décevants des élections
européennes
il s'agissait donc essentiellement pour
le premier secrétaire socialiste de
reprendre son parti en main au moment où
doit être rédigé le projet socialiste
ce projet guide politique économique et
social servira en quelque sorte de petit
livre rose au candidat socialiste à
l'élection présidentielle de 80 car à
travers le flot de déclarations
politiques de cet été on voit bien que
tout converge vers cet horizon 80 on
sait d'ores et déjà que la gauche n'ira
pas à cette élection avec un nouveau
programme commun on sait qu'il y aura
donc ce projet socialiste est
probablement un projet communiste
on sait enfin qu'au premier tour chacun
aura son candidat et qu'au second
il sera impossible pour l'opposition de
gagner si elle ne retrouve pas un tant
soit peu d'unité autrement dit le débat
s'amorce à peine à gauche interrogé par
tf1 pour la série les hommes politiques
en vacances michel debré jugent de façon
sévère la politique économique du
gouvernement
en des termes assez proches de ceux de
georges marchais l'ancien premier
ministre a d'abord dit à françois bonnes
mains qui est allé rencontrer à
préfailles dans la loire atlantique que
pour lui la hausse du pétrole n'explique
ce n'est pas tout la crise actuelle dans
un instant donc l'interview de michel
debré avec françois bonneau
j'ai dit que la hausse du prix du
pétrole n'était pas la cause essentielle
n'est la plus importante de la hausse
des prix enregistrée en france
voilà ce que j'ai dit et personne n'en
doute
la hausse des prix en france est dû à un
ensemble de phénomènes certains d'ordre
extérieurs dont la hausse du pétrole
mais certains dendre intérieur quand un
pays comme le nôtre un très grand et
très lourd déficit dans ses finances
publiques dans ses finances sociales
quand ils n'arrivent pas à dominer le
cycle hausse des prix hausse des
salaires hausse des prix le problème des
coûts de production et le problème des
prix connaître l'incidence à la hausse
tout à fait indépendante du problème du
prix du pétrole la hausse du prix du
pétrole est un phénomène particulier qui
a naturellement sa suite et comme je le
dis souvent il faut tu élever le débat
et se rendre compte que la france comme
le reste du monde est en état de guerre
économique nous avons et nous
continuerons d'assister à la guerre des
monnaies dont la baisse du dollar est un
des signes est le signe principal la
guerre des monnaies est la cause
principale de la guerre de l'énergie
dont la hausse du pétrole est le signe
est essentielle
il y a aussi la guerre du commerce et à
dire cette compétition qui abouti
notamment à des importations abusives et
sauvage et si je regrette l'insuffisance
de la lutte contre l'inflation qui est
la cause principale de la hausse des
prix c'est que dans la situation de
guerre économique où se trouvent les
français et on ne leur dit pas assez
la hausse des prix abouti à des
conséquences tout à fait fâcheuses pour
la production et pour l'emploi je le dis
je le dirai du cje être le seul à le
dire je le répèterai
souvent tant que l'on n'aura pas
expliquer aux français que le monde tel
qu'il est aujourd'hui tout à fait
différent du monde d'il ya dix ans du
monde il y a quinze ans est un monde
impitoyable où la guerre économique
sévit et bien on aura pour l'action
gouvernementale et pour la compréhension
des français on n'aura pas fait
l'essentiel
alors les autres justement il y en a eu
un certain nombre des buts de cet été
elles traduisent pourtant une certaine
vérité des prix est ce que vous n'êtes
pas en accord avec le gouvernement la
vérité c'est un mot qui est qui est très
souvent prononcée dans la bouche de
michel debré il ne suffit pas de la
liberté des prix et même la liberté des
prix et dangereuse quand par ailleurs il
y a un grave déficit du budget un grave
déficit de la sécurité sociale qui lie à
une absence de politique des revenus etc
en d'autres termes les causes de hausse
font que cette liberté des prix apparaît
comme une sorte de machine de guerre
contre le développement économique la
liberté des prix prise isolément à mon
avis n'a aucun sens
elle fait partie d'un ensemble et
malheureusement les autres pièces de cet
ensemble n'existe pas vous êtes un de
ceux qui qui inspirait quand même
l'action du rpr alors justement quelle
sera cette action du rpr à la rentrée à
l'égard du gouvernement et de sa
politique
ce que je peux dire en mon nom c'est que
déjà depuis quelques mois je considère
que le gouvernement de la france ne se
met pas et ne met pas les français
en présence de la réalité de l'année que
nous vivons et des années que nous
allons vivre une compétition considère
que ce soit la politique financière que
ce soit l'absence de protection du
marché commun il est tout à fait clair
que l'action gouvernementale n'est pas à
la hauteur des périls péril qui se
traduisent par la stagnation des
investissements et par le chômage dans
ces conditions l'attitude à l'égard du
gouvernement résulte non pas de ce que
nous pourrons penser mais de ce que fera
le gouvernement
et j'ose le dire de ce qu'il fera d'une
manière très différents
ce qu'il a fait jusqu'à présent perpère
a traversé une période un peu de gros
temps un peu comme on en connaît après
faïence moment juste après les élections
européennes à est-ce-que vous pensez que
cela va changer à la rentrée et vous
êtes celui que jacques chirac écoute
vous êtes celui que les militants et du
rpr reconnaissent un petit peu comme le
sage du mouvement donc quel sera
l'avenir du rpr comment voyez-vous
l'avenir dû refaire une chaîne devrait
il est l'avenir du rpr est liée à la
france je crois que nous sommes arrivés
à un moment où face au problème
la guerre économique face au problème de
la dénatalité face tous les conflits qui
sont actuellement ceux du monde
la france doit se redresser et doit être
un modèle la responsabilité du rpr et le
cas échéant son audience dans l'opinion
publique seront fonction de cette
fidélité à l'idée que l'on se fait de la
force de la france et que le bonheur des
français y est attaché le reste c'est je
reprends votre terme de la politique
politicienne qui n'intéresse plus
personne
ou quasiment plus personne l'art une
dernière question un peu plus personnel
est ce que vous allez vous êtes depuis
donc ces élections européennes un peu le
gardien permanent décédée eurent père à
strasbourg tél être le pivot
attendez je n'ai pas tout à fait terminé
est ce que vous allez pouvoir mener de
pair tout à la fois vos activités à
strasbourg vos activités à paris en un
mot ou est-ce que vous allez pouvoir
vous occuper tout à la fois des affaires
européennes et des affaires de la france
mais au sein de l'assemblée européenne
nous allons avoir une offensive
formidable contre la politique agricole
européenne
c'est l'intérêt de la france que je vais
défendre à l'intérieur de l'assemblée
traces bourg il ya une offensive
formidable contre l'indépendance
diplomatique et militaire de la france
ce sont les intérêts de la france et des
français que je défendrai naturellement
je souhaite défendre en août comme je lé
fais dès le premier jour une certaine
conception raisonnable de la coopération
européenne mais
n'en doutez pas le travail à paris et à
strasbourg est un travail complémentaire
et je le mènerai aisément de francs
malgré les attaques les critiques qui se
multiplient contre l'action économique
du gouvernement en tout cas la politique
de libération des prix va continuer
c'est le ministre de l'économie lui même
qui l'a précisé
pour rené monory les français ont été
mal informé la flambée sur les prix et
légumes notamment a été calculée dit il
sur trois produits seulement d'une
manière générale monsieur monory estime
que les commerçants se montre
raisonnable et que seul un détaillant
sur dix est en infraction étrangers le
polisario affirme avoir tué 25 soldats
marocains en lançant une attaque contre
la garnison saharienne de twiggy cet
engagement aurait eu lieu il ya deux
jours
les marocains gardent le silence sur
cette affaire en iran l'ayatollah
comédie aux prises avec le problème
kurde durci la répression 13 membres en
effet du parti démocrate du kurdistan
viennent d'être exécuté ce matin c'est
l' agence officielle iranienne qui
l'annoncent les 13 hommes ont été
condamnés par le tribunal
révolutionnaire islamique après avoir
été reconnu coupable de guerre contre
dieu et le peuple
hier d'autre part 11 personnes onze
officiers de l'ancien régime ont été
exécutés à téhéran et puis nouveau tour
de vis dans un autre domaine l'ayatollah
comédie vient de faire interdire 20
journaux dont l'organe du parti
communiste sur cette situation donc qui
se développent actuellement en iran vous
pourrez entendre en exclusivité au cours
de notre journal de 20h ce soir le point
de vue de l'ancien premier ministre
chapour bakhtiar toute l'amérique suit
les curieuses vacances du président
carter à bord du delta queen le chef de
la maison blanche alterne le jogging sur
le pont et les discours électoraux aux
escales tout en bavardant avec les
autres passagers
monsieur carter ainsi fait savoir qu'il
rédigeait ses mémoires et aussi qu'ils
lisaient deux à trois livres par semaine
à table dans son lit y même dit il dans
les toilettes
ces confidences ont pour but bien sûr de
faire remonter la cote de popularité du
président
pour un million de petits français les
vacances cette année en corse a été ou
ce sera avant tout la colo comme on dit
c'est dire l'importance des colonies de
vacances des colonies qui ont quand même
bien changé grâce à une législation plus
rigoureuse grâce aussi à une meilleure
qualité d'hébergement et d'encadrement
comme balmont très cette enquête
réalisée par marie laure augry c'est
vers les années 1960 que les colonies de
vacances connaissent une forte expansion
depuis une dizaine d'années c'est que le
nice ont quelque peu délaissé au profit
des centres aérés sans hébergement si
l'on bouge maintenant les colonies de
vacances est principalement semble-t-il
pour des raisons économiques
50% des enfants ne partent jamais pour
eux et centres aérés à la portée de
toutes les bourses sont alors les seules
vacances possibles
aujourd'hui un enfant sur 10 par an
colonies et colonies qui ont
considérablement évolué
c'est de toute façon un moment différent
dans la mesure où ils sortent du cadre
de l'école du cadre parental et qui se
retrouve donc dans un groupe d'enfants
souvent assez nombreux et avec des
adultes qui jouent un rôle différent par
rapport à eux
et ça ce sens là que déjà c'est un
moment privilégié que certains peuvent
juger artificiel mais de toute façon
leur apporte une expérience d'une
certaine manière unique
rien à voir avec l'économie
traditionnelle plus d'initiatives plus
de liberté moins de rigueur pas de
levier obligatoire par exemple on
respecte le rythme de vie de l'enfant
les activités sont libres chacun peut
choisir du cuir va poutrer aussi à la
piscine
on fait aussi des lampes et aussi on
s'amuse la nuit dans les dortoirs et des
batailles au plancher on essaye de faire
vivre les enfants dans un temps
différent ou un espace différent dans un
temps différent on aurait pu faire une
journée à thème sous le thème de la
préhistoire par exemple un retour à
l'âge de nos ancêtres
bon aujourd'hui on a choisi de faire une
journée à thème sur un autre pays sur
une culture différente et toute la
journée on s'essaye à vivre dans cette
culture
j'appelle les chameaux jack la
découverte d'un autre monde passe aussi
par l'accueil d'enfants de différentes
nationalités avec notamment cette année
l'accueil d'enfants quand bonne chère au
vietnam
chaque café ainsi l'apprentissage de la
vie en collectivité y acquiert des
notions de solidarité d'entr'aide et de
coopération
depuis quelques années grâce à un effort
de formation des animateurs des centres
de vacances ont acquis une valeur
éducative certains c'est plus chaude de
réponse à la tête de l'équipe de france
de football michel platini fera ce soir
ses premières armes de capitaine contre
le bayern de munich qu'il s'agit d'un
match amical c'est une bonne préparation
avant le match que les français doivent
ou disputer contre la suède
radiographie de cette nouvelle équipe de
france de foot avec didier roustan
didier roustan qui s'est intéressé
d'abord bien sûr aux nouveaux
sélectionnés ou au revenant à savoir
bergeron des coûts ou bac né il ya
seulement deux ans dominique bathenay
était considéré comme l'un des meilleurs
milieux de terrains d'europe
si vous allez faire un tour du côté de
liverpool vous entendrez encore parler
de ce fameux tir des 40 mètres sur
lequel s'était incliné de gardien de but
de l'équipe d'angleterre requiem avis
mais c'était saint-etienne c'était les
verts la coupe d'europe depuis son
arrivée au paris saint-germain bathenay
a rarement eu l'occasion de se mettre en
évidence cette année enfin l'équipe
parisienne a pris un bon départ en
championnat bat ne retrouve même le
chemin des filets nous revoilà donc en
équipe de france
pour eric pécout c'est différent le fc
nantes a toujours joué les premiers
rôles en championnat pécout a même été
le meilleur buteur français la saison
dernière mais elle arrivait toujours
rien si ce n'est 20 minutes contre le
luxembourg au mois de février dernier
eric pécout possède pourtant toutes les
qualités de l'avant centre moderne jeu
de tête frappe de balle engagement
physique
il s'est même se montrer très collectif
comme ici où il donne la balle de but à
loïc amisse leurs deux derniers matches
contre strasbourg il y a un an philippe
bergeron n'était que remplaçant à bordes
dans le même temps lille avait beaucoup
de problèmes au niveau de la défense un
transfert et le tour est joué
aujourd'hui lille possède la meilleure
défense du championnat quatre matches
rejoués aucun but encaissé et déjà un
penalty arrêté par bergeron bergerot qui
connaîtra pour la première fois ce soir
les joies de la sélection
en deuxième mi temps voilà l'équipe qui
s'alignera contre le bayern de munich au
parc des princes dans les bus il y aura
donc dominique dropsy chutes de neige
sur les alpes le retour des cigognes
dans le sud on en a vu ce matin dans
l'isère où elle faisait escale
vraisemblablement avant de regagner
l'afrique
bref côté météo les mauvais signes se
multiplient en fait seules les régions
méditerranéennes vont échapper au nuage
pratiquement partout ailleurs il pleut
ou il pleuvra et les températures
baissent mais je suppose que sous le
trou des halles on est bien à l'abri
c'est là que nous allons retrouver en
effet jean pierre pernaut et son invité
raymond moretti
oui nous retrouverons raymond moretti
dans un instant car nous sommes remontés
à l'extérieur de ce forum des halles
dont nous vous parlions tout à l'heure
la fresque elle est au troisième
sous-sol nous la rejoindront tout à
l'heure avec la moretti et ses invités
mais puisque nous sommes folles c'est
l'occasion de faire les points le point
sur se trouve dont on a beaucoup parlé
c'est sans doute le projet d'urbanisme
qui a fait couler le plus d'encre depuis
la deuxième guerre mondiale
alors messieurs saglio vous êtes
directeur général de la sema la société
d'économie mixte d'aménagement des
halles est ce qu'on peut faire le point
est ce qu'on peut et est ce que vous
pouvez confirmer d'abord que les travaux
aux pétales se termineront en 1983 dans
une affaire aussi complexe comme vous
l'avez dit on peut jurer de rien mais
notre planning actuel en effet c'est
d'avoir achevé l'opération en 1983 le
forum des halles cc l'essentiel
finalement non le forum des halles c'est
l'essentiel
à cause de tout ce qu'il ya autour que
les gens d'ailleurs imagine mal il faut
prendre la mesure des choses
l'opération des halles tout compris
représente grosso modo 700 mille mètres
carrés dans lesquels bien entendu j'ai
inclus le centre georges pompidou qui
faisait partie de l'opération des halles
j'inclus la station du rer
lorsque nous aurons ouvert la zone forum
qui va s'ouvrir le 5 septembre ou tel
que nous voyons sur ces images c'est ça
nous aurons grosso modo réalisé 450
mille mètres carrés donc il faut prendre
la mesure de ce qui reste à faire qui
n'est pas le plus compliqué ni le plus
important ayant un jardin aussi il ya le
jardin le jardin on peut discuter
beaucoup des dessins de jardin mais le
jardin en fait c'est un problème de
paysagistes jardiniers c'est sûrement
pas ce qu'il ya de plus difficile à
réaliser
revenons aux oeuvres d'art notamment
celle de mort et il n'y a pas que celle
de moretti dans ce forum non il y a en
effet quatre autres artistes qui sont
intervenus
dans le dans la zone forum un sculpteur
silva et trois peintres attila qu est qu
est rien
alors nous continuons à voir des images
extérieur de ce forum des halles en fait
c'est l'un des seuls c'est le seul
projet du projet al qui n'a jamais été
remis en cause depuis le début non on
peut aussi dire que la station du rer
n'a jamais été non plus remise en cause
ni le quartier piéton qui s'étend autour
effectivement par contre beaucoup
d'autres choses des remises en cause et
l'inauguration dans quinze jours de ce
forum des halles dont vous êtes le
promoteur monsieur guider et c'est vous
qui avez commandé la fresque à raymond
moretti la presse que nous avons vu tout
à l'heure avec nous en verrons tout à
l'heure nous avons commandé parce que ça
s'inscrive est tout à fait dans la
politique nous avait un petit peu
respirer la cmh de faire un quartier qui
soit véritablement un endroit où les
parisiens aient envie de venir de
retrouver à ce nombre de choses et nous
pensons que l'oeuvre d'art dans la rue
est un événement qui enrichit une
architecture générale est ce que ça ne
pose pas de problème de protection
la fresque que nous avons vu
elle pourrait être abîmée s'il est
beaucoup de gens passent devant bien sûr
tout dépend si on fait confiance aux
gens aux chanteurs fait pas confiance je
pense qu'il faut leur faire confiance il
faut aussi prendre quelques précautions
donc ici ce sont ici ce sera un centre
commercial et avec une animation
culturelle faut pas enlever ce boute
centre commercial ça n'est pas c'est un
quartier qu'on a voulu faire du début
c'était d'ailleurs le problème posé par
la ville de paris intermédiaire de la
cmh c'est ce que nous sommes et s'est
efforcé de faire de réaliser un ensemble
de commerces certes mais également un
ensemble d'activités de loisirs de
spectacle un lieu d'événements de
rencontre a lieu d'accueil d'information
donc de mêlée au maximum le
les équipements et les raisons de venir
pour les visiteurs qu'ils soient
parisiens provinciaux étrangers il ya
quarante mille mètres carrés de surfaces
commerciales quand il ya quarante mille
mètres carrés de surfaces commerciales
qui vont ouvrir le 4 septembre mais le 5
septembre exactement mais il y en a
encore 6000 à ouvrir en entier des
superstructures qui elles seront
terminées pour 1983 que nous aimons
c'est celle octroyée qui si tout sera
terminé pour le 4 septembre parce que là
il ya encore beaucoup de bruit autour de
nous beaucoup de travaux en cours mais
ça c'est le miracle des chantiers bien
sûr le ferons tout pour ce soit terminé
et nous ferons tout pour que les
parisiens qui viendront lui rendre
visite le 4 et 5 septembre ne soient pas
déçus
évidemment il ya beaucoup de 18 ans
chaque patient bien monsieur qui déjoue
remercie mais il ya aussi un autre
problème il ya le contenu bien sûr de ce
forum est aussi larchitecture nous avons
vu quelques images tout à l'heure nous
allons revoir car alain beguerie ni avec
lui l'un des architectes du projet forum
qui a été avec son associé monsieur
pencréac'h les architectes qui ont
travaillé sur ce projet pendant combien
de temps et pendant sept ans c'est à
dire que nous avons fait le concours
puisque la sema à l'origine a lancé une
consultation pour le forum des halles
c'est un concours messieurs guidée en
titre de serre et aménagements nous a
demandé de faire ce concours avec lui et
donc en 72 nous avons répondu à cette
consultation nous avons rendu le projet
de concours en 72 nous avons appris en
janvier 61 ce que nous étions les
lauréats de ce concours est depuis
janvier 73 jusqu'à maintenant et encore
un peu puisque ce n'est pas tout à fait
terminé nous travaillons d'une manière
continue sur ce projet qu'est ce qui
vous a séduit si vous voulez dans la
commande qui vous a été passé
le projet lui même la situation le
quartier l'aspect commercial l'aspect
rue intérieure
écoutez pour nous le problème a été je
dirais évident et immédiat
nous avions d'emblée comme de problème
nous a été posée au niveau de la
conception penser qu'un tel équipement
aussi important ne peut pas exister s'il
reste sous terrain et s'il est
complètement coupée delà des relations
extérieures et la lumière naturelle le
poisson qu'ils ne pouvaient être vivable
au viable que si réellement ce projet
randy nation et puis puisse faire
disparaître complètement cette notion de
souterrains il faut quand même voir que
c'est un projet qui se développe sur un
quadrilatère que 200 mètres sur 200 m et
sur quatre niveaux de hauteur entre le
rer et le niveau des rues piétonnes au
niveau parisien des rues et tout notre
problématique a été de dire foncièrement
tous là tout ce qui nous a passionné
dans ce projet c'est de le rendre lui
intégrer le maximum de lumière naturelle
en créant cette immense cratère centrale
qui fait que quels que soient les
niveaux où nous nous trouvons comme vous
le voyez ici on a le sentiment d'être le
plus directement en relation extérieure
c'est à dire nous avons répondu
principaux principalement à trois
objectifs le premier c'est que le rer
qui tout en dessous que les gens qui
sort du rer puissent rapidement être en
relation avec l'extérieur la lumière
naturelle
ce référé ça nous paraît fondamental le
deuxième que par la création de cet
espace central ce grand cratère entouré
de verrières il ya une espèce d'éléments
centrale la combat entre le centre du
projet qui parce que quel que soit les
gens qui déambulent dans ce projet dans
le forum
il est une référence avec l'extérieur
ils sachent tout de suite où on se situe
par rapport à quoi par rapport à ses
attaches par exemple par rapport à
l'extérieur de paris et qu'il ya une
espèce de lieux d'identification de ce
projet qui est la place basse et la
place minérale et que troisième point
c'est que ce place minérale complète les
places de paris et permettent en fait
d'obtenir au clair de paris à l'endroit
peut-être un des endroits les plus
prestigieux c'est à dire le coeur les
halles une place minérale
je dirais presque à l'italienne comme il
n'en existe pas à paris est entièrement
piétonne il n'y a jamais de bruit
est-ce que vous avez été est ce que vous
avez été frappé par le quartier par le
style du quartier sainte eustache vous
il faisait référence tout à l'heure les
arcades que l'on voit ici rappelle un
petit peu les architectures de
saint-eustache
oui ça n'a pas été directement à la
connotation pour nous mais s'il voulait
nous avons toujours cherché à présenter
à travers ce projet a montré
saint-eustache qui est le monument le
seul monument du quartier que l'on voit
directement on a toujours cherché à
l'exploiter depuis l'origine
mais si vous voulez vous parler de ce
langage rond si vous prenez par exemple
les toits de la rue de rivoli à paris
qui sont 6,3 en zinc
ils sont parfaitement quart de rond un
petit peu on peut trouver ce genre de
connotations vous prenez le grand palais
bon il est également avec les mêmes
sarki les ronds mais pour nous
fondamentalement nous pensions avant
toute connotation parce que l'idée est
aussi liée à l'organisation interne du
projet nous avons développé des buttes à
l'intérieur des voûtes ronde qui font
que on a voulu que ce langage existe
aussi dans la verrière et des six
provinces et aucune continuité de
langage qui est une architecture parce
que nous pensons fondamentalement que
l'homme ne peut pas être sur la lumière
naturelle mais il en est de même de
l'architecturé un projet n'existe pas si
on peut pas jouer avec la lumière
naturelle au maximum en cas d'un projet
la lumière naturelle éléments
d'architecturé le plus important
monsieur vasconi je vous remercie je
vous je vous interromps que j'étais
passé aux explications passionnantes je
vous remercie et nous avons pu pénétrer
grâce à vous les premiers dans ce forum
des halles qui ne serait inaugurée que
dans quinze jours
dans un instant nous nous retrouverons
près de la fresque de raymond moretti là
aussi une exclusivité moretti qui
connaissait bien l'ancien quartier des
halles puisqu'il a travaillé ici pendant
trois ans sur son monstre dans l'un des
pavillons de balle tu as regardé un
reportage réalisé en 1973 avec un
document qui donne l'occasion de rendre
hommage à l'un des meilleurs amis
raymond moretti joseph kessel
à deux pas du marais s'étendent et les
halles de paris aujourd'hui installé à
rungis baltard renier les pavillons
détruits il ne reste aux pieds de
saint-eustache qu'un énorme trou
le dernier locataire du dernier pavillon
lui aussi à des ménages
le peintre moretti a dû trouver un
nouveau gîte quand son monstre oeuvre
gigantesque qui s'abritait là depuis
trois ans
forest de plexiglas de faire de bois aux
dimensions monumentales 30 mètres de
long 15 de large 8 2 euros ne pouvait
trouver de meilleurs cadres que la
défense
les urbanistes de la défense ont
enseveli sous 30 mètres de béton au
coeur de la nouvelle ville au carrefour
des autoroutes l'oeuvre de moretti
là le monstre va croître et embellir la
défense a trouvé son âme et cette âme se
visitent futur chapelle du 21e siècle
les adeptes du culte prendront le rer et
suivront les fitch
et vu le noyau d'une toute petite partie
de ce qui allait être le monstre dans un
tout petit studio à la victorine à nice
et déjà ce noyau cette première
structure était tellement étonnante
était tellement inqualifiable dans le
sens la beauté de la nouveauté de la
richesse que le mot est venu
spontanément à bouger dîner c'est un
monstre magnifie le voilà tout à coup à
la défense dans les entrailles
extraordinaire de ces bâtiments de
l'avenir au centre d'une ville nouvelle
ce que j'admire le cadre est hissé au
dessus de lui quelque chose qu'on
appelle destin hasard rien ne permettait
de penser qu'il achèverait
d'ailleurs qu'il n'achèvera jamais
puisque le continuer comme on continue
un poème qui n'a pas de fin
d'un personnage qui se livre peu sauf à
ses amis il a deux passions dans la vie
c'est son travail et l'amitié et il ne
va pas aux gens mais l'un ce magnétisme
un char ou pas dans le sens facile
charme enfin à mon charme dans le sens
fort qui fait qu' il attire les gens les
plus différents les conditions de plus
composer des tempéraments les puis mon
frère d'équité qui vit dans un milieu il
il lui faut s'adapter à ce milieu il
faut en même temps qu'ils absorbent ce
milieu est aussitôt son génie créateur
veut se servir des matériaux plusieurs
chansons
oui il est à l'aise partout il a
d'ailleurs un petit atelier démontable
qu'il transporte partout qui est
installée en deux heures et il est là
tout lui est égal critiques us travail
shige tour en gris fondés
gilles ait un avocat vous aurez c'est
vraiment sur ce document pourquoi
compter les mêmes et enfin en moins
depuis quinze ans et il m'étonne
toujours
hamon
raymond moretti nous faisons l'entente
de joseph kessel s'est elle à nouveau
meilleur ami
gfk sell était mon second perd
finalement et je suis très très ému
d'avoir une bande cassel et vous avez
vous aviez aussi pour amy cocteau
picasso beaucoup de gens très très
célèbre picasso cocteau et puis plein
d'amis qui ne jurent qu'ils ne sont pas
célèbres joseph kessel disais tout à
l'heure et tout le monde s'en souvient
qui avait deux choses importantes dans
votre vie c'était l'amitié et votre
travail
on va pas vous demander quel est le plus
important des deux mais j'aimerais
savoir le carax et l'amitié l'amitié
avant le travail quoique c'est l'amitié
et dieu sait si je travaille mais je
crois que ça passe avant
alors vous apprêtez beaucoup d'amis
s'élèvent en disant moretti c'est l'ami
de picasso c'est l'ami de kessel c'est
l'ami de cocteau et c'est alors qu'en
fait ceux qui vous connaissent un peu
savent que vous avez des milliers d'amis
parce que les gens qui viennent voir
aussi bien le mot sur la défense que les
gens qui vont venir ici voir cette
phrase que gigantesque deviennent peu à
peu pour ceux qui le perçoivent vos amis
et vous avez le contact souvent avec ce
qui s'est passé quand j'étais aux halles
la rue ce qui se passera sa violence et
que si je sors avec une femme qui est de
ma taille on ne remarque pas je sors
avec une femme de dos m donc célèbre
qu'il soit en en marquant n'y tiens il
sort qu'avec des grandes femmes ont
parlé de la meet me on parlait de
l'amitié de votre travail qui est
important votre travail aujourd'hui
c'est cette c'est cette fresque immense
qui est derrière nous et qu'ils
commencent par les origines tout à
l'heure vous nous disiez laethem le
thème de cette fresque c'est l'homme ça
commence par les origines de la non mais
c'est à dire le côté gauche c'est toute
l'histoire physique et le côté droit
histoire culturelle
alors là c'est l'eau c'est notre grand
père c'est le plus vieil européen
l'homme de tautavel qui est très à la
mode en ce moment c'est il a cinq cent
mille ans il est très vieux faut faire
très attention et il m'a paru très bon
que les gens à paris dans la rue et
leurs ancêtres le plus vieil européen
dans la rue en 2 m de haut rang bronze
400 kg je trouve que vous êtes très
intéressée par ses origines de
l'humanité par l'homme de tautavel et
par les autres comme en témoigne ce
commentaire de jean claude perpère
en 1974 alors qu'il continue à élaborer
le monstre et semble fasciné par sa
vision fantastique quelques inquiétante
de l'avenir moretti plonge subitement
dans le passé un passé lointain de
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'années
il s'inspire alors de l'évolution de
l'humanité de découvertes archéologiques
successives réalisée par le professeur
de l'ucl et lui font prendre conscience
du vertige des origines c'est la
découverte du crâne de tautavel vieux de
450 trident et surtout la mise au jour
en plein coeur de nice sa ville natale
du campement préhistorique de terra
amata date et lui de 350 pilotes alors
pour le musée construit sur ce gisement
il sculpte cette monumentale vague
d'acier où il inscrit une arabesque de
bronze le symbole de la longue marche de
l'homme vers les temps modernes
mais ce prodigieux du futur imaginaire
dans un passé encore énigmatique n'a pas
mis un terme à lèvres de mort écrit il
n'a pas pour autant épuisé ses sources
d'inspiration tout simplement on peut se
demander si à partir d'ici
l'angoissé origine n'a pas rejoint celle
de l'avenir raymond moretti comme on
l'évoqué jean-claude perpère il via un
lien dans votre travail entre le grand
passé le très grand passé cinq cent
mille ans en arrière
et puis le futur parce que si on se
souvient de la phrase de garaudy vous
concernant moretti va au futur comme on
va au taureau donc vous êtes l'homme qui
est à mi chemin entre le grand passé le
grand futur est ce que c'est une
décision qui vous plaît puis il ya une
ligne une colonne vertébrale comme ça
qui me suis tout le temps
c'est dire qu'ici au forum j'ai repris
le thème que j'ai fait pour la de la
façade du musée terra matar dire je
repartis de l'homme de tautavel pour
faire une fresque ici à paris
c'est à dire que j'ai je continue
finalement une oeuvre qui a commencé
qu'en chine et peut-être donc je suis le
fils peut-être à voir mais ça c'est mon
affaire met donc je suis il ya une
continuité comme ça je suis toujours
dans des locaux souterrains par exemple
je ne sais pas pourquoi
puis toujours jamais à la lumière du
jour toujours à la lumière électrique
de vastes panneaux et j'ai une ligne
continue comme ça avec l'eau en plus qui
me surveillent partout j'ai toujours des
problèmes d'eau alors pour réaliser
cette fresque que vous avez réaliser
vous même vous êtes entouré ça je crois
que c'est quand même unique de jalousie
à trois collaborateurs c'est peut-être
pas le mot en tout cas de trois amis
avec qui vous avez élaboré le projet de
cette phrase il y à philippe sollers
il y as marck payer et il y à armand
gatti collaborateurs qui m'a suivi
fidèles c'est le chinois
daniel en fou qui restait près de moi
toutes les nuits en trois mois du doigt
comment trois personnalités aussi
différentes que celles de marc payet
philippe sollers armand gatti alliée à
la vôtre ont pu donner cette fresque
gigantesque mais je reviens à ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure les amis
passent avant donc j'ai établi une sorte
de computer de cerveau voyait a4 ou a3
pour toi sont plutôt à 3 je lance une
information fait ce que je pense et ça
se balade entre comme ça finisse en
europe
ils sont une information que je choisis
c'est à dire je ne sais d'ailleurs je ne
suis pas obligé de faire ce qu'il dit
alors je peux choisir dans the tree of
rage ne prends ça je le prends ça je
vous laisse et puis je relaie
l'information mais ils sont tous les
trois différentes il ya un lien c'est
les amis alors sur cette fresque quelle
a été la participation de chacun armand
gatti ma participation je crois qu'elle
a été tout à fait défini en un mot c'est
celle de l'ami disons et en plus de ça
une complicité très profonde entre
moretti et moi c'est à dire que nous
sommes tous les deux fils d'émigrés
italiens fils de travailleurs émigrés et
je crois que ça constitue plus qu'une
nationalité le besoin de conquérir tout
un langage et aux différents stades de
cette conquête
je crois qu'on s'est toujours retrouvé
le mur le texte et de gastines c'est
c'est à dire qu'après que très peu de
mots denise il ya très peu de mauvais
parce que les mots après sur un de
cheikh sadek ils deviennent de la
peinture ils deviennent physique plus
ils vont vers le centre ville de vienne
visite à dire qu'ils prennent ne
lâchèrent ils prennent des formes
mais ces mots sont de gatti philippe
sollers alors l'intellectuel philippe
sollers que fait team dans cette fresque
écoutez moi c'est très simple leur
demeure et il passionne parce que je
crois qu'elle est au centre de ce qui
préoccupe tout l'art moderne
c'est-à-dire faire une oeuvre ouverte
vous savez on peut dire qu'il ya deux
conceptions de l'aria une conception
fermée comme il ya deux conceptions de
la société il ya société fermée la
société ouverte et je trouve que cet art
qui est justement un art ouvert ouvert à
tous est ouvert à une récapitulation de
toute l'histoire de l'humanité sacem ça
me préoccupe beaucoup d'aces pas aller
de 500 mille ans du plus vieil européen
ou plus nouveau européen qui est
d'ailleurs un homme complètement inconnu
qui ne demande qu'à immergée de ce
souterrain dans lequel murray dit
travail voilà le problème
alors avec ça il faut une récapitulation
culturelle intense qui passent pas
énormément de références à beaucoup de
choses très importantes de l'histoire
non seulement de notre pays mais distant
de la culture en général
par exemple victor hugo qui est là et
bien ces dernières nous c'est l'homme
qui a écrit la légende des siècles et ce
mur est un peu comme la légende des
siècles qui apparaît d'ailleurs dans le
problème du go comme étant la
récapitulation de tous les âges de
l'humanité vers un futur qui nous est
absolument inconnu qui ne peut être que
neuf
alors voilà ce qui m'intéresse dans
cette célèbre ouverte parce que ça veut
dire sociétés ouvertes et vous savez
qu'il ya un philosophe anglo saxons on
parle beaucoup maintenant qu'ils
s'appellent pop qui a écrit un livre
très important qui s'appelle la société
ouverte et ses ennemis et bien il ya
toujours eu un conflit entre les
partisans de l'ouverture de la société
ou de l'art et les partisans de sa
fermeture
c'est très simple il ya des
révolutionnaires ou il ya des créateurs
novateur et il ya des académiciens et
des académies que qui songe toujours à
restitution analyser à refermer les
choses moretti et comme la vieille taupe
dont parle marx qui travaille justement
dans les souterrains du futur il doit
vous avez remarqué qu'on n'a pas on n'a
jamais dit à propos de moretti le
peintre moretti le sculpteur moretti
nous avons jeté les étiquettes mais
j'aimerais quand même savoir philippe
sollers est ce qu'on pourrait dire le
philosophe moretti mais certainement je
crois qu'on peut dire tout simplement le
visionnaire moretti c'est quelqu'un qui
voit
rose qui voit les choses dans sur une
longueur d'onde plus ample et plus
profonde que la plupart des gens et qui
révèle peut-être aux autres leur vision
parce que tout le monde
tout le monde est visionnaire seulement
il faut ouvrir les portes ouvrir les
frontières ouvrir les murs pour que tout
le monde puisse être visionnaire je
crois que c'est une oeuvre de vision
marc payet je vais vous demander en tant
que confrères vous faire quand même une
petite synthèse nous avons écouté armand
gatti évoqué sa sa familiarité son
cousinage avec avec raymond moretti nous
avons écouté philippe sollers
alors marc payet quoi faut-il dire de
quoi faut-il dire de cette de cette
fresque fait pour celui qui va placer et
celui qui va passer va regarder cela et
on peut supposer qu'au premier abord il
va être un peu déconcerté mais ce que
nous avons voulu faire je crois est ce
que vraiment on a voulu faire d'abord
c'est quelque chose dans la quête
progressivement on entre qu'on lit qu'on
des chiffres qu'on découvre et plus on
entre à l'intérieur plus on découvre des
sens le sens des lettres le sens des
mots le sens de l'histoire
le sens des couleurs le sens des formes
et cela donne à lire tout ce que
philippe à dire actuellement tout ce
qu'il a montré ce que armand a dit
l'amitié l'amitié pour raymond la
chaleur humaine l'histoire tout cela il
faut que progressivement un effort de la
vision de la lecture on le voit quand on
passe là devant et c'est pourquoi cela
qui n'a pas l'air fantastiquement
construit et prodigieusement construit à
mon sens et je crois vraiment dans les
trois dimensions
c'est à dire avec une espèce de
profondeur de lecture dans le temps et
je dois dire que dans la réunion
d'amitié
raymond a fait cela nous nous sommes ses
amis dans la réunion d'amitié
cette espèce d'idée qu'au fur et à
mesure que les gens parce qu'on a devant
ils pénétreront davantage dans ce qui
nous paraît essentiel et chaleureux ça a
été le soutien de tout notre effort et
qui nous a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
aidé vous avez une dernière question
pardon jean-pierre dernière question à
raymond moretti
quel serait votre sentiment si les
milliers de gens qui vont passer ici
dans un mois ne sentent pas ne
perçoivent pas même une parcelle de
votre fresque je ne saurai jamais le
savoir est ce qu'il ya un rapport quand
même avec le public est ce que le public
de la sentir doigts comment vous allez
établir ce contact vous vous avez
travaillez vous avez fini est-ce que je
peux je fais ce que je sais je le mets
sur le mur et ce qui se passe après ce
n'est plus de mon ressort du tout quoi
si si ça peut apporter quelque chose je
suis très très content mais là vous
verrez vous faire confiance à la
jeunesse admettre interpellé raymond
moretti le monstre n'est pas terminé
cette phase que là est terminée ou
est-ce que vous allez continuer sur
d'autres murs des halles ni un bain à un
brevet de vaincre ni de sculpteur je ne
suis pas un artiste je fonctionne alors
si on me demande quelque chose si je
sens je peux le faire je le fais comme
aurait dit merci messieurs également il
est l'heure maintenant de rejoindre rené
tendront à la bourse de paris où on
attendait beaucoup jean pierre pernaut
voir comment le marché de l'or allait
réagir aux déclarations de françois
mitterrand évoqué tout à l'heure sur
l'union de la gauche et bien c'est le
calme en général vous allez le voir les
cours de l'or vrai peu varié sur le
marché international et laura paris la
barre aussi bien que le lingot ont peu
bougé également la pièce française de 20
francs le napoléon est un n'a pas changé
vos loyers au premier cours 400 francs
virgule 10 en réalité on a monté un peu
derrière on est dès maintenant à 4 103
81 mais ce n'est pas la plus forte
hausse la plus forte hausse aujourd'hui
sur le marché de l'or c'est la pièce
suisse de 20 francs à 384
quant au napoléon lui-même son mouvement
vous allez le voir sur le graphique que
nous allons vous présenter maintenant le
mouvement du napoléon remonte tout de
même un certain temps déjà
il a suivi et même accentué le mouvement
général de la hausse de l'or vous le
voyez à la fin du premier trimestre en
gros on peut dire que le napoléon a
commencé à grimper plus vite que le kilo
d'or fin pour la simple raison c'est que
le poids d'or contenues dans l' napoléon
a toujours
lui un petit peu plus cher que le poids
du lingot et que les cours n'avaient pas
suivi depuis 1976 alors maintenant la
prime à rattraper nous en sommes à peu
près un niveau de 60 % plus cher que le
lingot alors que nous étions tombés à 35
% ce qui vous expliquent cette hausse a
s'est accentuée du napoléon les emprunts
indexés eux ont peu varié aujourd'hui -
4 francs pour le quatre et demi pour
cent plus 10 francs pour le 7 % et les
valeurs françaises ont assez bien réagi
aux déclarations du ministre de
l'économie sur la nécessité de maintenir
la libération des prix dans le domaine
industriel vous avez vu un certain
nombre de hausse assez sensible parmi
les valeurs françaises dont dumez en
tête est au plus haut de l'année le
petit carré vert vous l'indiquait il ya
tout de même des baisses aujourd'hui à
la bourse de paris vous en voyez ici un
certain nombre en troisième position by
équipements société de leasing à 236,6
premier et dernier cours est au plus bas
de l'année un petit corps est rouge vous
lundi qu avec des échanges modèles sont
voix qui hier pas plus de 300 titres ont
été échangés
les baisses sont souvent des prises de
bénéfices et une majorité de hausse est
enregistrée donc aujourd'hui parmi les
valeurs françaises comme parmi les
valeurs étrangères
la bourse de new york était en hausse
hier soir et vous voyez avec le
rectangle vert
l'indication que il y a beaucoup de
valeurs américaines qui sont aujourd'hui
parmi les plus forts mouvements de
hausse aux valeurs étrangères également
les mines d'or qui sont en reprise
hier elle avait beaucoup beaucoup baissé
et donc une séance satisfaisant aussi
bien du côté étranger que du côté des
valeurs françaises
aujourd'hui nous avons dans l'ensemble
une bonne séance ici la bourse de paris
avoue jean pierre perrin
merci rené tendront un dernier retour
ici au forum des halles au troisième
sous-sol avec cette fresque que nous
avons découvert en exclusivité cette
fresque de raymond moretti que vous
pourrez mieux découvrir si vous voulez
mais si vous appréciez ce qu'il vous a
dit tout à l'heure ce que vous en dise
est émis grâce à un livre qui paraît en
ce moment en librairie moretti carrément
aux éditions encre un livre meeting avec
andré bercoff fin de ce journal
vous le voyez au milieu des travaux le
forum des halles ne sera ouvert que le 4
septembre au revoir et à demain pour une
nouvelle édition de tf1 actualité